what about this idea that could the
world just bifurcate
um where where you have more that like
country like if you have like countries
that align more like the US and U.S
values
um versus you know thinking like China
Russia
um first of all it's happening
um
and by the way I would say
it's less really around values
than it is around practicalities
you know who am I trading with what's
who's going to economically militarily
it's just basically economics and
Military who's going to be advantageous
um
and so
you know so it's happening that way
um however
we are
extremely connected and when you have
the bifurcation it's extremely costly
and extremely risky
so we're having it like each country is
thinking if I was to go to war will I be
self-sufficient okay and and then the
develop developing of resources to try
to be self-sufficient doesn't lend
itself to efficiency that's not the
primary objective
and then to disconnect
is is very very difficult you know
um we are you know
um
electronically digitally uh connected
to the fraction of a second getting
people or stuff from one place to
another is shorter than it is has ever
been
and it's a and it's a very risky
environment so bifurcation
um means by the way of the example less
harmonization less World Order